all right let's dig in my friends to the
topic of coronavirus and vitamin D
here's why I'm doing this today medical
research is looking at so many different
things when it comes to coronavirus
everything from testing antiviral
therapies looking at convalescent plasma
transfusions of antibodies looking at
you know our cases more severe in cities
with more air pollution versus cities
with less air pollution all of these
things are being looked at and they
should be but when we throw a whole
bunch of stuff out it can be hard to
really think through just one element of
this any of these could be fruitful in
thinking of how to treat the virus but
we really want to dig in deeply and and
think through all of these different
possibilities so one thing that's coming
up more and more is the connection
between coronavirus deaths and low
levels of vitamin D so let's explore it
vitamin D is most importantly for humans
something that helps us absorb calcium
magnesium and phosphate and humans can
get vitamin D from the Sun you go
outside you get it from from UV light
and from very few foods fish is the big
one sometimes mushrooms if the mushrooms
have absorbed UV UV light as they were
growing there are many countries that
when you buy milk the milk is reinforced
supplemented with vitamin D some
breakfast cereals are supplemented with
vitamin D okay but vitamin D has been
controversial over the years for a while
it was very much in fashion to do a
significant supplementation of vitamin D
then we learned more about high vitamin
D toxicity and so we've backed off of
that a little bit but for a while if you
were below 30 nano grams per milliliters
let's just call it 30 right with the
exact measure doesn't doesn't matter but
if you were below 30 in vitamin D you
were considered to be low and should be
supplementing more recently 22:30 has
sort of been considered okay and a lot
of people now say a lot of medical
professionals say you really only need
to supplement if you're below 20
nanograms per milliliter of vitamin D
there's not a hundred percent agreement
on that there is also the general idea
although the space
ethics are always complicated that low
vitamin D can increase all cause
mortality basically low vitamin D can
make you more predisposed to die and
that you are generally more susceptible
to diseases of various types if your
vitamin D is low so how does this relate
to coronavirus well it relates because
we now have a bunch of studies that have
found correlations between coronavirus
deaths and serious cases of coronavirus
and low levels of vitamin D particularly
with levels of vitamin D under 20 to
some degree people with vitamin D
between 20 and 30 and very infrequently
are the deaths happening in people with
a vitamin D level above 30 now right
away our critical thinking skills should
kick in and say David is this
correlation or is this causation and
that's exactly the right question
because if this is causal it would imply
that if you take vitamin D and raise
your level to 30 your odds of dying from
coronavirus or having a serious case go
down dramatically but we don't know that
we don't know that it is possible that
the people who died with low vitamin D
died because of some third factor that
causes low vitamin D let me give you an
example if I'm suffering from severe
cardiovascular disease and I am inside a
lot because my mobility is decreased I
could have a predisposition to die from
coronavirus because of the
cardiovascular disease and I might have
low vitamin D because I'm not going
outside very much because of the
cardiovascular disease in other words if
you have cardiovascular disease and you
take vitamin D you might not be
protecting yourself from a coronavirus
death we don't know is the point what
does the caller scholarship say so far
we have a bunch of different studies we
can look at there's one paper called
vitamin D level of mild and severe
elderly cases of kovat 19 a preliminary
report looked at a hundred and
seventy-six patients over age 60 who had
severe Kove at 19 and indeed a lot many
of them a lot of them had very low
vitamin D another study called vitamin D
deficiency as a risk factor for severe
kovat 19 looked at 180
six patients and again they found that
the coronavirus patients had lower
vitamin D than the median population at
large in particular men so does this
tell us vitamin D protects you from
coronavirus no it does not
sadly no there's also another
complicating factor because there are
studies which find that vitamin D levels
go down when the body suffers a
traumatic event for example a surgery
but there's also speculation that if you
get a lung infection or lung
inflammation that can reduce your
vitamin D so if that's the case corona
virus could be lowering vitamin D levels
making the case for vitamin D being a
protective force even less clear if you
get a lung inflammation and it lowers
your vitamin D if you then supplement
vitamin D does that protect you we just
don't know so where do I come away with
this
here's my perspective and it's not my
opinion it's from what I've read from
medical experts
it seems that maintaining a vitamin D
level above 30 without going up into the
toxic range is generally a good thing
vitamin D is really cheap you can get it
for free from the Sun taking care to
protect your skin of course it's one of
the cheapest supplements that you can
buy so I recently got an at-home vitamin
D test it was you know the end of the
Boston winter I have not been outside as
much as I'm outside during the summer
and my level was thirty point five just
above that minimum so I am not
supplementing I eat plenty of fish I'm
spending more time outside now as long
as my level doesn't go super high
there's very little risk and very little
cost to ensuring that I maintain above a
thirty in vitamin D seems reasonable to
me
of course always consult with your
doctor this is a general consensus from
the medical community and not advice for
any individual that's vitamin D and
coronavirus by next week we may know
more